he moved from Hong Kong to Canada when
he was 14 years old when he came to
Canada he had no money and didn't speak
English
he started and failed that 13 businesses
before finding success he's Dan Locke
and here's my take on his top ten roses
success volume 12 enjoy
okay let's kick it off with real number
one build self-esteem here's the number
one success secret that no one talks
about and no one shares this is
something I've learned from my mentor
dan penny at the fifty billion dollar
man self-esteem is the foundation of our
success now I'm not talking about
arrogance I'm not talking about pride
I'm not even talking about just
confidence I'm talking about self-esteem
now what is self esteem self esteem is
something that your parents didn't give
you think about when you're growing up
when you want to do something when you
want to take some risk what do your
parents what do your friends what did
they tell you you're not trained for
this no one in our family is an
entrepreneur or you don't have enough
education or you don't know the right
people just be content right be happy
with what you have or hey son I want you
to be successful but not too successful
I want you to think about what is
holding you back the goals that you have
that you want to achieve why don't you
do what you know deep down that you are
supposed to do why don't you take that
risk why don't you stop that business
what's stopping you because you lack
self-esteem now the next question you
might have
Sifu Dan how do I build my self-esteem
let me give you a perfect example let's
say you have a friend of yours and he
tells you all the time hey man let's
let's hang out say okay you know what
let's hang out let's go grab a drink
let's go
you know go for a hike every single time
he says okay let's do something he would
cancel on you and there happens again
and again and again so let me ask you a
question if there happens all the time
how would you feel about this friend
this person would you trust him or her
not so much the reason you don't
have high self-esteem because you have a
lousy track record meaning how many
times you promise yourself that you're
gonna do something but you don't how
many times you make promises to yourself
and you don't deliver you don't follow
through on those promises and guess what
when you do this enough for enough times
for enough years you have low
self-esteem because you know you know
yourself well yeah I guess I want to do
that but I'm not gonna follow through
I'm not gonna make it happen and that's
why your self-esteem is low you don't
even believe in yourself little things
big things you make a promise to
yourself and you deliver rule number two
be driven successful people are
incredibly driven how driven are you now
I'm not talking about you being a
nightmare to work with or bullying other
people I'm talking about you pushing
yourself to get results it's your
personal Drive that turns your ideas
into actions into results it is your
personal drive that keeps you going when
things get tough it is your personal
Drive enables you to bounce back from
disappointment from setback so how
driven are you or are you lazy do you
procrastinate do you put things off you
see for the first five years of my
career I didn't take a single day off
I was working 10 12 14 hours every
single day's for five years strict why
because I was driven I was driven to
provide for my family I was driven to
prove other people wrong and today I am
driven by my mission how driven are you
rule number three don't be negative you
are walking down the street and some of
you here
hmm and suddenly you see a red Ferrari
just drove by what's the first thought
that comes through your mind comment
below
no filter no edits just comment below
what's the very first thought that comes
to your mind
my guess is chances are he's an [ __ ]
who does he think he is
so cocky so selfish probably a greedy
bastard actually you know Polly's not
his money anyway it's his daddy's money
or if it's a lady's a woman oh that's a
gold digger right
all these negativities guess what that's
you judging other people my question to
you is how do you know how do you know
it's all made-up stories in your mind
right and you say oh he's not that good
she's not that pretty he's not that
smart you're judging other people you're
projecting your own insecurities your
own values on the other people how do
you know that man is not a hard-working
man how do you know he's not a good
husband how do you know it's not a
family man how do you know he's someone
who's worked 20 30 years to get to where
he is at this point how do you know you
judge you come to your own conclusions
before even talking to the person you
see how your mind works how are you
gonna be successful how are you ever
gonna become rich if that's the image
that you have for people who are
successful rule number four do what
works for you you see this on social
media very often people talk about the
morning ritual or waking up very very
early in the morning because all are
successful people they all wake up in
the morning so do you actually need to
wake up early early in the morning to be
successful that's one of the problems
with people don't know how to filter
advice now are there a lot of people who
are successful who wake up in the
morning absolutely
but are there also a lot of people who
are successful who don't wake up in the
morning absolutely right but it's this
propaganda on social media that people
focus so much on that success has to do
with your habits what you do on a
consistent basis and
you have to know what time in the data
you're the most productive for some
people it is early in the morning where
there's no distraction these people are
still sleeping and you go through the
day maybe you go work out maybe you do
meditation then you plan the day that's
fine for some people they don't wake up
early they wake up whatever time and
then they work late at night they're
more like a nail
I'm Malik Anaya I find that I am the
most creative late at night when it's
quiet when there's no noise right when
there's not a lot going on I find that
that's those quiet times sometimes
become my thinking time so that's what
works for me I think you find what works
for you doesn't matter whose advice
you're getting from it could be for me
could be from anybody else but you have
to know yourself enough if it doesn't
work for you if you get up in the
morning you're like oh my god I'm so
tired you're sleepy you're exhausted and
for many many days and Dutch just like
it screws up your biological clock then
it doesn't work for you and that's kind
of one thing that I gravitate towards
Bruce Lee's martial art as you follow my
work you know I'm a martial artist that
Bruce is always about you finding your
own path that's why he said his martial
art style is not a style it's a set of
principles you define what works for you
I've sold what it's a useful reject what
is useless and what is eventually on
your home also if you want to have more
confidence second by 254 confidence
series it's free the link to join isn't
a description below after you practice
martial art you develop this natural
self confidence not cockiness but you
develop this natural self confidence
rule number five practice martial arts
the fact I like martial art because it's
it's not a physical
sure it's a mental sport that's right
right because a lot of time well you can
play tennis all you can play golf play
all that it's nice
yeah but martial art is a sport where
they say I'm hitting a heavy bag Yeah
right
doesn't matter how good you get and
you're competing with yourself press
right and it's all about the limiting
eliminating your own defect I can throw
a punch mm-hmm well I can twelve punch
we're gonna hit it with speed if I can I
hit it with power that's all that I need
to learn and practice and do all that
stuff so I love that part of it and it's
a never-ending challenge
it's never good it's never good enough
you find someone that can do it faster
bigger like stronger for sure I love
that there's always someone that's gonna
be better than and I can go super
philosophical right where I can not how
about physical like it just goes off an
esophagus it and I can do that extreme
and I love that crazy deep dive of life
and philosophy I love that aspect I love
it rule number six don't make excuses
you can make money or you can make
excuses but you cannot do both an excuse
is nothing more than a well planet lie
you see the excuses ego sets well I
can't afford it I don't have money right
oh oh oh that's too far oh that's too
too difficult to I don't have enough
experience it's always I can't I can't I
can't
oh I don't know how you see you could
have a million excuses why you cannot do
something
you only need one damn good reason why
you must do it rule number seven don't
fear failure one of the things that
holds people back that I believe is fear
fear of failure I want you to ask
yourself this question what would you do
differently if you knew you couldn't
fail would you take more risk would you
be more aggressive you don't need to be
afraid of failure I'll give you a
perfect example when I was making an
offer
when I was driving people to take an
action and investing in themselves when
I'm speaking to a group of audience
maybe a hundred people 200 people 500
people on a good day I might have 10 15
20 percent of the people in the audience
they would take action and they would
invest in themselves so you would say
well that's a 20 percent success rate
yes that is as 20 percent success rate
but the other way to look at this is
basically I fail even on a good day
eighty percent of the time I would get a
rejection eighty percent an audience
would say no in marketing when you are
running traffic when you're doing your
marketing online let's say you get a
three percent conversion meaning a
hundred people this is your website
three percent will take action they say
your conversion of three percent ninety
seven percent would say no 97 percent
would not buy and 97 percent would not
take action well guess what you have a
97 percent failure rate you see anyone
who achieves any kind of success
experience failure on a consistent basis
rule number eight overcome adversity
whatever you're going through right now
I know may be very very difficult and
they almost finished at the end of world
and you're only the world right the only
the world I want you to imagine that you
are now three years five years maybe
even ten years from today and now you're
looking back and what's happening right
now and you ask yourself some of these
questions is this bad as I thought it is
what can I learn from this I know it's
very difficult you say I not learn
nothing from it there's nothing I'm not
even this no what are some lessons you
could you could take away what some the
value given this right this is going to
be the most difficult one what could you
be grateful for that this happened to
you
and you're like oh come on come on then
there's nothing to be grateful for this
accident happened this emergency
happened or something tragic that has
happened like just nothing that could be
grateful for I know but if there is
something you could be grateful for what
could you be grateful for ask yourself
those questions suddenly that would give
you perspective and when you come back
to reality where you are now to looking
at scenario okay if it's changes from
now maybe it's not as bad imagine even
things that happen to in the past
the adversities that you experienced in
the past think about that it could be
two three five ten years ago back then
that felt like the end of the world that
felt like it's the worst thing that's
ever happened to you back then now
looking today looking back back then how
do you feel about those incidents my bet
is this it's not as bad as you thought
and you learn a lot from it and probably
you find something that you could be
grateful for that
that adversity turns out to be one of
the greatest thing that's ever happened
to you rule number nine master the skill
of communication back then when I was
going to high school in Canada in
Vancouver I had no friends right
because I was very much an introvert I
was very shy because I couldn't speak a
language when I first arrived to this
country I couldn't speak a word of
English so I was very afraid to talk to
people of course when you're afraid to
talk to people no one will listen and I
remember I would try to communicate very
various even simple language simple
words with my classmates and they're
like what what it's a part of me and I
would have to repeat the same thing
three four or five times and because
they just won't listen and eventually
they pretty much just lose their
patience they're like I know I can't
understand you man I can't understand
we're talking about so they don't want
to talk to me because they feel it's
it's it's very troublesome for them
right
so I know for a fact when you see what I
do when I'm now communicating with you
that I can speak I can command an
audience an offense you know from all
over the world that communication this
is a learnable skill it is a what
it's a burnable skill this is something
that you could learn I could go from
some of us a totally introvert shy no
one would listen to me to now that
people would listen to what I have to
say right and you'll never attend the
last one before a very special bonus
clip is be yourself number 10 the fake
Eagle have you ever met someone that you
don't know them but the minute you meet
with them they just have this weird kind
of vibe that you don't trust him or her
or they feel very fake then you feel
like oh my god they're just so fake
they're so superficial that you don't
make that connection that they are not
genuine or have you ever met someone
that's just a minute you meet with them
you make the instant connection and then
there's that trust that says that bond
that you feel this person is sincere the
fake eagle maybe that's you maybe that
you're very good at putting on this mask
you're very good that in one
circumstance you can be this person in
an other scenario you become a different
person and then here you become another
person and before you know it you've
done it for so many years you don't know
who you are anymore
you don't know which one is the real you
which one is the real you you've lost
yourself be yourself everyone else is
taken be yourself I will rather people
hate me for who I am then love me for
who I am not so don't don't use the fake
eagle you don't need it to be successful
now I'm gonna special bonus clip from
Dan on how to put yourself first that I
think you're gonna enjoy but before that
it's time for the three point landing
question let's go from just watching the
video to taking action here we go
question number one
you need to stop being negative number
two what is working for you that you
need to do more of and number three what
excuse are you going to stop making I
don't want to rock the boat
right as long as everybody's okay then
I'm okay you try to please people too
much
you always put other people first
nothing wrong with that but sometimes in
life you have to put yourself first even
when you're flying on an airplane you
got to put on your own your own oxygen
mask first before you help someone else
sometimes in life you have to put
yourself first you have to be a little
bit selfish so you could be generous hi
this is Dan Locke if you're a fan of
Evans work if you want to know exactly
how the model my success I want to
invite you to join me for a special
online training all you have to do is
click on a link below you can join me
for absolutely no charge so click a link
below and I will see you in class
if you want more dan lock chuck at the
top 50 rules video made on him the link
is right there next to me continue to
believe and I'll see you there
if your life stinks is your fault we
take responsibility for all action our
money is not the important money doesn't
buy happiness oh my goodness let me
think
[Music]